find the value of k for which f has a
critical point at x equals negative 5.
all right so let's just remind ourselves
what f of x and f prime of x were they
gave it to us at the top f of x is equal
to 1 over
x squared minus kx and then f prime of x
is equal to all of this business let me
rewrite it
let me rewrite it down here
so
f
f of x
is equal to 1 over
x squared minus kx
and f prime of x
is equal to k
minus 2x
over
over x squared minus kx
whole quantity squared
and we want to find the value of k for
which f has a critical point at x is
equal to negative five
so f has a critical point at x equals
negative five
this means
this means that x
that means that
x
equals negative 5 is in domain
so this is
in domain which means our function
itself
is defined at x equals negative 5
and
it means that
f prime of negative 5
is equal to 0
or undefined
or
undefined a critical point is a member
of the function's domain where the
derivative is equal to zero or it's
undefined so let's evaluate f prime of
negative five
f prime of negative five in terms of k
is going to be equal to k
minus 2 times negative 5 minus 2 times
negative 5
all of that over
negative 5
squared minus k
times
negative 5
and then we want to square all of this
and so this is going to be equal to k
plus 10
k plus 10
over
we have 25
what is this 25 plus 5k
25 plus 5k
plus 5k
squared
so what value of k makes f prime of
negative 5 equal to 0
well f prime
of negative 5
is equal to 0
if
k is equal to
negative 10. so that's a value of k for
which f has a critical point at negative
5.
now you might be saying well what values
of k that's the value of k that makes
the function equal zero it makes the
numerator equal zero and therefore makes
the whole function equal to zero but why
can't i pick out k a value of k that
makes that makes the derivative or it
makes the it makes the numerator of the
derivative zero and so therefore it
makes the derivative equal to zero i
think i said function not the derivative
of the function but you might be saying
well why can't i pick a value of k that
makes the derivative undefined and so
you could think of what that is what
would make this undefined well if 25
plus 5k is equal to 0 well then this is
going to be you're going to have 0
squared you're divided by 0 it's going
to be undefined so you could say
f prime of negative 5
undefined
undefined
if
k is equal to what negative 5
right 5 times negative 5 plus 25 is a
zero
but this if if k is equal to negative 5
then this can't be a critical point
anymore x equals negative 5 can't be a
critical point because it won't be in
its domain anymore if k is equal to
negative 5 then f of x would be equal to
1 over x squared
plus 5x
plus 5x and then f will not be defined
at negative 5. and so negative 5
couldn't be a critical point because
it's not even in the domain so the
important thing is in order to be a
critical point it has to be in the
domain and the derivative of that point
has to be equal to zero undefined i can
get the derivative to be undefined at
negative five if we set k equals
negative five but if we set k equals
negative five then x equals negative 5
will no longer be in the domain so we
want we want to go with the k that just
makes the numerator of our derivative
equal to 0 or sets our entire derivative
equal to 0.